here
are some simple quick beauty tips from
someone who
really knows what they're talking about
how to properly wash your face step one
your water should be lukewarm that myth
about hot thin cold water is so bs
step two wet your face easy right step
three pour out an appropriate amount of
cleanser lather up a bit and then start
to wash your face keep in mind you
should be gently gliding your hands
across your face don't forget to wash
along the hairline area oh wait i know i
have a hairline step four rinse your
face with lukewarm water
so easy step five either pat dry or air
dry
experiment with both to see which one
you like now for the most important part
if your skin gets dry dry like this you
waited too long you should never let it
get this dry
unless the next product you use requires
the skin to be dry dry like when using a
retinoid clay mask chemical exfoliant
etc but it should never be dry dry don't
waste time watching my tic tocs go
straight into the rest of your routine
while your skin is damp
however make sure that your skin fully
absorbed each step before continuing to
the next once you moisturize then you
can relax so yeah that's how you wash
your face dude i'm going to show you how
to do a quick and easy smokey eye
using no makeup brushes just your
fingers
the first thing we're going to do is
give our eyes a little bit of a base
using a nice creamy liquid eyeshadow dab
some of this at the corners of my eye
and then just smudged much much with my
finger next thing i want to do is come
in and define a little bit with an
eyeliner pencil
not being too precious about it really
smudge it
next step i'm going to come in with kind
of this darker gold color
smudge much fudge come in with my pinky
and just this nice light gold
come in here to the inner corners just
dab it along my brow bone this is a nice
goldy smokey eye you can use any colors
that you like a little bit of mascara
and there you go hi drew so my beauty
secret is
very simple and it's just ice you
basically just go
all over your skin it helps with
inflammation it helps with puffiness
especially when you're breaking out if
you put it over
any type of blemish it helps take away
like the inflammation of that and the
redness
it gets really cold but do as long as
you can generally i wait till the ice
cube is melted
completely i'll just keep going all
around my face so i'll start at the top
and kind of just move all the way down
to the bottom
i really um focus on the areas that are
kind of inflamed like i say
around my eyes where it's kind of puppy
i like to kind of
release that it's actually something i
also use when i was on the bachelorette
because honey sleep is no thing on the
bachelorette okay
so i would constantly try to figure out
little
tricks and tips to kind of help my skin
look
awake and vibrant and in the morning
it's super easy
i'll just take one of these rub it and
then put my serums on
and do my makeup and go i'm lo bosworth
i'm the founder and ceo of love wellness
we make clean
total body care for women everything
from multivitamins to supplements to
personal care products and my beauty
secret
is fiber most women it turns out
not getting enough fiber in their diets
every single day
you think oh it should be easy to get
enough fiber for my fruits and
vegetables but how often are you really
having five or six
servings of fruits or vegetables every
day so
i started to increase my fiber intake
about two years ago and it really
changed my life for me the first thing
that i saw was clear
glowing skin because if your digestion
is optimized
you're removing toxins more frequently
from the body the second thing that i
started to notice
is that my energy was improved the third
thing i started to notice
was that i was way less bloated fiber
acts like a broom as it moves
through your body and digestive system
it pulls out toxins it pulls out gunk
that's been sitting in your small
intestine forever
and eventually it exits the body so i
take three capsules of sparkle fiber
every day
with my other supplements i drink it
with a big glass of water and then
boom my digestion is improved my skin is
glowing and i feel great
thank you for sharing that with us
[Music]